[MUSIC PLAYING]
DENNIS HUO: Good
afternoon everybody
and thanks for coming.
To set the stage a
little bit, I want
to begin with what you
probably already know.
Hadoop and its
ecosystem tools have
become increasingly crucial
for businesses of all types.
And this is in large part
for its promise of providing
a way to unlock
value and insights
from your data at massive
scale, and in particular
to do so with
unprecedented agility,
so that you can
quickly react day
to day to changes in the
landscape of your industry.
Now since you're here
today in this session,
you've probably also
encountered, and maybe
dealt with yourself personally
too, this unfortunate fact
that your
administrative overhead
and operational complexity
of managing your Hadoop
infrastructure is also scaling
up, and perhaps superlinearly
with the increasing
sophistication
and the diversity
of your workloads.
And this is something
that threatens
to undermine the very
value proposition that it
brings in the first place
by eroding that agility.
So that's where Google
Cloud Platform and Cloud
Dataproc come in.
We'll see how a
migration to cloud
and an incremental
reorganization of the way
you think about your
Hadoop infrastructure
and your Spark workloads
can let you preserve
all the power of
this open source
stack that you've built
your systems on already,
but also to remove
those brick walls
and let you get back to
focusing on your data,
focusing on your insights.
So my name is Dennis Huo.
I'm tech lead of
Google Cloud Dataproc.
And in today's session, we'll
be going over deep dive,
end to end of what it looks
like to migrate your Hadoop
and Spark workloads to
Google Cloud Platform.
Now along the way, we're going
to find that no steps really
have a one size fits all
answer for everything.
But rather, we'll be focusing
on some overarching guiding
principles and reusable
building blocks
that you can use to build
the right migration strategy
for your business needs.
So let's begin with, what
is Google Cloud Dataproc?
Dataproc is Google Cloud
Platform's managed Hadoop
and Spark service.
Its overarching goal
is ultimately just
to help tip the scales
away from having
to think about Hadoop as
low level infrastructure.
So to help illustrate
a little bit
of what it means
to be fast and easy
and cost effective,
imagine, if you will,
the next version of
Hadoop or Spark comes out.
The shiny new version
promises something
like a 10x speed up of all
your workloads or, say,
you can simplify one of
your 10 stage pipelines
into a one liner in Spark.
So just consider, what might
it take to go from that time
where you've heard
about these versions
and want to try it out to
being able to deploy this,
to canary this and be ready
to switch over your production
pipelines to the latest and
greatest at full production
scale.
Well, with Dataproc, it should
be no more than a one liner
on the command line,
or alternatively, just
about four clicks on
the Cloud Console.
And about 90 seconds
later you should
be up and running with
the latest and greatest,
ready to canary your workloads
even at full production scale.
And this same kind of
speed and simplicity
is also what lends itself
to cost savings, ultimately,
because you can more easily
ensure that you're only
deploying the resources that
you need when you need them.
So right off the bat, you can
significantly reduce your cost
just by making sure that
you're actually paying
for what you actually use.
To put this in perspective
in the big picture,
ultimately there
is a whole spectrum
of approaches to running Hadoop
on Google Cloud Platform.
And this ranges from
thinking about GCP
as your infrastructure
to thinking
about GCP as a platform.
Now along this whole
spectrum, Google
works with third
party Hadoop vendors
and provides open source
connector libraries and tools.
So in general, your
migration doesn't
have to be an all or
nothing proposition.
Now some of the concepts that
we're talking about today
are going to be applicable no
matter what kind of approach
to Hadoop on GCP you
take, while others
are going to be highlighting
new architectures that
are made possible by moving
to this fully managed
Dataproc side of the spectrum.
Taking a peek under the hood
at how Dataproc is made,
Dataproc layers in features
in between the layers
of the underlying Hadoop
stack, and adds these features
for easy visibility into
status and monitoring,
adds control hooks and
configuration hooks
for things like
managing your clusters,
resizing your clusters,
optimizations.
But it does so on top
of the open source
interfaces of the Hadoop
stack, ultimately.
So what this means
is Dataproc adheres
to the principle
of letting you drop
down one level into the lower
level stack whenever you need.
So you don't have to abandon
any of your low level,
advanced customizations
if you don't want to just
to get the value added
features of Dataproc.
You can bring all that with you
and still keep those low level
customizations.
So as an example here, we have
Dataproc clients and raw Hadoop
clients.
So if you want, you
can interact entirely
with your Dataproc
clusters using
the standard underlying raw
Hadoop clients, connecting over
to TCP.
And if you don't want
to, you never even
have to acknowledge the
existence of Dataproc's Jobs
API.
On the other side
of spectrum, you
might choose to only
interact with your clusters
through Dataproc Jobs APIs,
through these standardized
web-based REST
interfaces, and never
even have to be the
wiser about VMs existing
under the hood at all.
But both of these
options are available.
Dataproc's Hadoop
distribution is
based on the open source
Apache Big Top project,
and natively will
install and support
Pig, Hive, Hadoop, and Spark.
Other ecosystem tools like
Tez, Zeppelin, and Kafka
can all be activated from the
Dataproc distribution using
something called initialization
actions, which are just scripts
that you can use to customize
your Dataproc clusters
for your own needs.
So that brings us to planning
a proof of concept, or a POC.
Thinking back to that
on-premise static cluster,
you may find yourself becoming
increasingly dependent
on increasingly monolithic
Hadoop clusters.
And in a lot of ways,
some of the key strengths
of Hadoop as a
great data platform
are also the source
of its weaknesses.
And what I mean by
that is there are
all these components
in the Hadoop ecosystem
that make it so
easy, they're so well
integrated with the
rest of the Hadoop stack
that it's easy to augment
your existing Hadoop
cluster with powerful tools
like Oozie for scheduling
or Zeppelin or Jupiter
for data science, maybe
various HiveServer2 clients.
And along the way, you
don't really notice,
but then one day
you'll look back
and you'll see
that somehow you've
dumped all this systemic
complexity in one
place on your cluster and
loaded it down in such a way
that it's that much more
difficult, in aggregate, to now
reshape or rearchitect
your workloads when
it becomes necessary to do so.
So what this means
for your POC is,
as you're thinking
about how to migrate,
you want to make sure you're not
just thinking about forklifting
your entire Hadoop
stack onto GCP,
complexity and messy
hacks included.
But instead you want
to think about keeping
your eyes open for opportunities
to simplify your architecture
as you go.
This is something that, as
you keep in mind that clusters
aren't an end unto themselves,
that no single cluster should
really--
you don't want single clusters
to constitute your entire data
analytics universe in a
sealed, hermetic way anymore.
You think about the broader
platform on the whole.
So for example,
you'll use clusters
as building blocks towards your
greater data platform at large.
And perhaps you'll use BigQuery
for the bulk of your data
warehousing needs.
Maybe you'll find that
Stackdriver is the easiest
way to unify your logging and
monitoring across all your GCP
services.
Now as one of the first
steps towards your POC
and subsequent
migration, you'll want
to make sure that you
outline your high level
goals, the driving forces of
what you're trying to get out
of your migration to GCP.
And typically these are going to
be high level goals that can be
achieved in any number of ways.
So for example, if you're
thinking about cost savings,
you'll want to make sure
you're thinking about price
performance and total
cost of ownership
instead of getting stuck
on comparing CPU for CPU
or byte for byte storage.
Another example in
terms of scaling
elasticity-- if you're
unlocking this elasticity,
GCP isn't just a way to speed
up the hardware requisitioning
cycle.
It can be.
It can be a faster way
to requisition hardware
in a traditional way.
But really, you get the
most mileage out of larger
architectural changes.
So for example, by separating
out your storage and compute
and scaling them independently,
or separating out
different workloads and
scaling them independently,
this is how you can achieve
the best scalability for what
you've paid for doing this
migration in terms of making
changes to your architecture.
Now these are just
some examples of goals
that you might come in
with and how GCP features
might relate to them.
Ultimately you know best
what your driving goals are.
And this is how you will shape
your overall migration plan.
Now it's probably also
worth mentioning right now--
I know I've been talking
a lot about change,
change this, change the
way you're thinking,
change your architecture.
And admittedly it's scary
to talk about change.
Change comes with
cost in itself.
It can be a source of
complexity in itself.
And it's definitely
a valid concern
to think about the
cost of change.
But what's important is both you
should neither write off change
altogether, nor should you
blindly accept change as good.
So it can be good,
it can be bad.
But it doesn't have to
be a significant cost.
And there are definitely
opportunities here,
during your Hadoop
migration especially,
for low hanging fruit where
the cost isn't that significant
and you have significant
benefits for the long term
viability of your architecture.
So as long as you're weighing
those costs and benefits,
that's what's important,
even if it doesn't always
land on the side of choosing
that big architecture change,
as long as you know what's going
into that decision to do so.
On a more concrete level,
you'll want to identify as much
of the characteristics that
go into the requirements
of your long term
architecture as possible.
So really characterize
your existing stack
and figure out
what you're doing.
And I focus on the
characteristics
less so than the requirements
because ultimately you're
not just coming up with a
checklist of requirements.
By characterizing your stack,
this is a great opportunity
to identify what
components you really love
and which ones are really
providing you value long term
and will end up in your
long term architecture,
while you'll find
that a lot of things
are really just workarounds or
a means to an end, that actually
bring you pain but were a
necessary evil in the meantime,
and something that you can
really slice out complexity
with by doing your
cloud migration
and adopting something
a little more cloud
native for those pieces.
On a more practical level,
the logistics of planning out
your timeline and
capacity planning,
that's something that you'll
want to do early on as possible
in your workflow.
So coming up with your estimates
of what you'll need over
the course of your migration
to make sure that you're not
suddenly blocked by
something silly like a quota
request when it comes
time to actually ramp up
your migration.
So that brings us
to data migration.
This is one of the first
concrete technical items
that you will be tackling
during the course of your POC
and migration.
The cornerstone of
all your migration
is likely to be the Google Cloud
Storage connector for Hadoop.
So this is a connector that
Google provides and implements
the Hadoop file
system interfaces
on top of Google Cloud Storage.
So we strive really for
out-of-the-box compatibility.
So this means that,
for the most part,
your migration will take
place using familiar Hadoop
tools that you're already
using inside your Hadoop stack,
running simple
DistCp jobs into GCS.
Other options that we
provide include HDFS
on persistent disk, which
comes standard with Dataproc.
Or alternatively
you might consider
using local SSD as a higher
performance alternative.
So good for things
that require--
where you might want
to pay a little bit
extra in order to guarantee
very low round trip latency
for things like business
intelligence or online data
analytics.
Slightly larger
architectural change
involves potentially replacing
your entire HBase cluster
with Google Cloud Bigtable.
So in the same vein as GCS
being a file system replacement,
Google provides HBase compatible
clients for Cloud Bigtable
so that you can transparently
migrate over any workloads that
normally run against
HBase and use Google Cloud
Bigtable instead and treat
it like an HBase cluster.
And this is something
that will drastically
reduce your
operational complexity
by no longer having to manage
your HBase cluster yourself.
Another option is using BigQuery
for your data warehousing
and SQL based analytics.
So in the same vein we provide
connectors for BigQuery,
for Hadoop, so
that you can still
interact with your
storage in BigQuery
while doing the
bulk of your data
analytics in BigQuery
itself, with zero ops,
without managing your clusters.
Timeline-wise, some of the data
storage plans that you take on
will help shape your
migration strategy in itself.
So as an example,
one recurring pattern
is you might find that you're
archiving data into GCS.
Or you might find
that regardless of how
you want to migrate
your workloads,
you're starting to do disaster
recovery backup into GCS.
So in these cases,
it's very natural
to start adopting ad hoc use
cases inside of Dataproc.
So now that your data
is already there,
you might find that an
unexpected backfill comes up.
And you can use Dataproc
to get that done quickly.
Or maybe new
pipeline development
where you don't want to
occupy space on-premise,
it's a natural fit for
using ad hoc Dataproc usage.
Digging a little bit deeper
into the compatibility of GCS
and HDFS, like I mentioned,
the GCS connector
is designed to be compatible for
the vast majority of Hadoop use
cases, so a drop in replacement.
Anything that uses file
input/output formats,
Spark text, binary files,
all these things just
work without you having
to think about it.
That said, there are
some caveats, right,
because Google Cloud Storage
is an object store, not
a file system.
And this is something
that's becoming also
increasingly common within
the Hadoop ecosystem itself
is to use these object stores.
So different cloud providers
and private cloud solutions
like OpenStack Swift also have
similar object store semantics.
And this is something that's
recognized and becoming
better supported within
the Hadoop community itself
day to day.
So that will get better.
But in the meantime,
it means that there
are some more specialized
HDFS features that
might require still using HDFS.
This includes
directory semantics.
So an object store
doesn't actually
have directories, so
you don't have things
like directory access times.
Additionally, objects
are immutable once they
are created.
So one use case that might still
do well on HDFS instead of GCS
would be if you have a workload
that requires appendable files.
In general though, a
lot of these constraints
come from architectural designs
that are actually benefits.
So for example, some of
this increased round trip
latency comes as a result
of no longer having
any single point of failure
or any single bottleneck.
So you can have arbitrarily many
files in a single GCS bucket
if you want, a single GCS
directory, because it's all
massively distributed on
Google infrastructure, right?
And as an implementation
detail, that
means there's an extra
layer of indirection,
which is why latency might take
a little bit longer round trip.
In general, the same principles
for optimizing your HDFS
workloads applies
to GCS as well.
So using small files can hurt
in terms of round trip latency.
So avoiding lots of
small reads, avoiding
lots of sequential small
metadata requests, using bulk
reads of data whenever possible
all still equally apply to GCS.
So to visualize what it might
look like to actually run
this data transfer from your
on-premise cluster into GCS,
there are generally
two categories.
You can have push-based
or pull-based transfer
of your data.
The most
straightforward way here
is push-based where you simply
install the GCS connector
on-premise and use
the same public APIs
to access GCS as
any other client.
So this is a very
straightforward approach
as long as you can modify
your on-premise cluster
and you have some spare capacity
for running, say, DistCp
MapReduce jobs.
And this will just
push everything
over your public
internet gateway
into Google Cloud Storage.
And in-transit,
GCS requires HTTPS.
So everything is protected
by that SSL layer.
As an alternative,
if you can't do that,
you can set up a
Cloud VPN gateway
to bridge your on-premise
network with a Compute Engine
network.
So Dataproc supports
deploying your clusters
into custom subnetworks
that have all the IP
address and firewall rules that
you need to make your VPN work.
So once you've
bridged your networks,
Dataproc cluster is
being built on raw,
native, compatible Hadoop
clients can, out of the box,
interact with your
on-premise cluster
and pull data out
through that VPN tunnel.
So you simply specify
your HDFS colon slash
slash on-premise name node path.
And everything just works.
And one benefit of running
Dataproc clusters like this
to pull the data
out of on-premise
is that you can use
Dataproc's cluster sizing
features in order to adjust
your transfer rate as needed to.
And this also doesn't have
to be putting data into GCS.
You might be performing these
transfers into HDFS on Dataproc
instead.
So that brings us to some
overarching cloud architecture
concepts.
Like I mentioned before, there's
no one size fits all answer.
So again, these are just
some building blocks
that you can assemble into
your own migration strategy.
But these are recurring
patterns that are well utilized
in a variety of places.
So to begin with, I
want to think back again
to that on-premise cluster.
And traditionally,
Hadoop places a lot
of emphasis on data
locality and bin packing
and things like this.
And it makes a lot
of sense in that it's
common to get to come in
and provision a cluster--
and plan out a Hadoop cluster
based on storage size.
So you'll say I need like
an x petabyte cluster,
and that's a certain
number of disks.
And you can adjust your
CPU and RAM a little bit.
But in large part, you're
still driven by saying,
you need X petabytes of storage.
And you just have to
plan to then make do
with what compute comes
with it, for the most part.
And ultimately, this
is a leaky abstraction.
This is letting storage
implementation details start
to dictate application
layer decisions of how
your workloads are shaped and
how your workloads are sized.
So on Google Cloud
Platform, you don't have
to worry about bin packing.
That's Google's
problem to worry about.
And instead, you can separate
out your storage and compute.
And not only do you get your
cost savings by only having
to pay for what you're
actually using and having
independent scaling,
this actually
also simplifies your
workflows, because you
don't have to
worry about shaping
your workloads to the right
size for your hardware anymore.
But rather you do it
the other way around,
pick the right hardware
for your workflows.
So this is a concept
that actually
unlocks a lot of other
architectural concepts as well.
And to put it in
terms of number,
imagine if you have a job that
takes say, 10,000 vCPU hours.
On cloud, it costs the same
whether you provisioned 20,000
vCPUs for half an
hour, or if you
provision 100 CPUs
for 100 hours,
if the math works out-- yes.
So in that case,
it costs the same,
but the data is so much
more valuable to you
now rather than later.
So you don't have to try to
slip it into some spare capacity
and let it run between the
cracks of some existing
infrastructure.
You just burst into the
cloud and get the job
done immediately so that you
can have the data as quickly
and as valuably as possible.
One nice feature of Compute
Engine that Dataproc natively
supports is preemptively VMs.
So preemptively VMs are
just like any other VM.
They operate just
like any other VM.
The only difference is that
Google reserves the right
to reclaim these
VMs, to reclaim them,
preempt them if other on
demand or production workloads
make it necessary.
And as a result, they only cost
20% of the normal cost of a VM,
so a significant cost savings.
And normally it might
be difficult to manage
these kinds of things,
joining and leaving
your cluster by yourself.
But on Dataproc,
that's Dataproc's job
to make sure that it replenishes
these VMs if they leave
the cluster and make sure that
they smoothly join and leave
the cluster over the
course of your workload.
So that means that it's
basically just fire and forget.
You set your number
of preemptible VMs
on your data cluster,
let the job run,
and you get better
price performance.
Another Compute Engine feature
that Dataproc natively supports
is custom VM types, which Urs
talked about in today's keynote
as well.
These, again, go
back to the notion
that you don't have
to worry bin packing.
That's Google's problem.
So you don't have to worry about
stranding resources because
of an oddly sized workload
or having to underprovision
for a given workload, right?
Pick exactly the right
mix of CPU and RAM
that you need, and
Dataproc will work it out.
Dataproc will dynamically
calculate the right Hadoop
and HDFS configs based on
the actual requested amount
of CPU and RAM.
One of the bigger
architectural concepts
that is enabled by that
disaggregation of storage
and compute--
and I mentioned
this a little bit
before too, is
that you don't want
to think about single clusters
as your entire universe.
You don't want
your Hadoop cluster
to be your hermetically sealed
data analytics universe.
Instead, the broader
platform as a whole
is your data analytics platform.
And so in this concept,
you'll separate out
different workloads
into different clusters.
That way this
eliminates a lot of
this multiplicative complexity
where you try to bin pack
a lot of different things
into the same place.
So you can significantly
simplify things that way.
And what's more, you can
independently optimize these.
So for example, you might
find that some workloads,
like say your
business intelligence
or your online
analytics, prefers
paying a little bit more for
very high performance and very
predictable performance.
So you might opt for
something like HDFS on SSD
and cache a lot of
your data assets
inside of that HDFS
for fast performance.
And on the other hand, you
might have some overnight ETL
pipelines, batch jobs, that you
just want to optimize for cost.
So in that case, they can be
completely differently shaped.
You might mix in a
lot of preemptible VMs
to sacrifice a little bit
of that predictability
of variable job run time in
order to get much better cost
savings.
In the same vein, not only
can you chop up clusters
based on the shape
of your workloads,
but also chop them up in
terms of your lifecycle.
So what this means is on
the far end of the spectrum,
if you have ephemeral
clusters, this really
gets rid of a lot of
the headaches that
come from dealing
with high complexity,
long lived clusters,
so single use clusters
that are made possible by
Google's minute granularity
billing and fast
deployment time.
And this makes it trivially easy
to ensure that your hardware is
able to evolve in lockstep
with the evolution
of your workloads.
This also means things
like even migrating
to a whole different region
are as trivial as flipping
one configuration value in
your ongoing ephemeral cluster
workload.
In the middle
ground, there's also
this notion of using
semi-long lived clusters.
So in this case,
instead of using
a single very large and
forever lived cluster,
chop it up into a small
handful of semi-long
lived clusters where you can
still preserve much of the look
and feel of an
always on cluster.
You always have clusters
available there.
But instead, you're sort
of load balancing your jobs
into individual clusters
inside a group, transparently.
And by doing so, what you can
do is, for example, if you want
to canary a brand
new version, you
get a nice hermetic environment
for performing this A/B
testing.
You can canary one entire
cluster unto itself
without any risk of
leaking over and breaking
your other production clusters.
But you can canary that
with a brand new version,
naturally let some amount
of your production workloads
go to that cluster.
And if it's all green, it's
very easy to now upgrade.
You're not trying to change
the tires on a moving vehicle
anymore.
You get to do this in chunks
one cluster at a time.
Similarly, you don't have
scaling bottlenecks anymore,
or single points of
failure, because now you
can keep adding more
clusters to your group
in order to increase your
scale without worrying
about the single
bottleneck of scaling.
So that brings us to managing
your clusters and jobs.
So I want to take a
look at what it actually
looks, what it actually feels
like to manage your clusters
and jobs on Dataproc.
And I have slides
here for posterity.
But we will do this
live in demo so you
can get a better feel of
what it actually looks like.
So I mentioned before, a one
liner on the command line.
And this one is a
little bit more complex.
The basic command
that you'll run is--
whoops-- gcloud dataproc
clusters create.
Give it a cluster name.
And actually you can hit
Enter right then if you want.
In my case, I'm going to
call this dhuo-demo-1.
I'm going to give
it five workers.
I'm also going to
turn on this property
for enabling
Stackdriver monitoring.
So you can see how we can
build some custom dashboards.
Also I'm going to attach a tag.
You'll see how that
plays into everything.
And importantly I've also
put a time command here.
So you can keep me honest.
We can see how long this cluster
actually takes to deploy.
So these are all clients
that are based on Dataproc's
web-based REST interfaces.
That means that you get
ubiquitous and consistent
access from everywhere.
Excitingly, one of
my colleagues is also
concurrently using
this demo project
to do another live
demo next door.
And while that is doubly
tempting for the demo fates,
no reason to be worried
precisely because we're
using different clusters.
It doesn't matter if we're
sharing the same resources.
It's completely safe.
We can do anything we want.
We won't break each other.
As I mentioned, so
kicked of that cluster
from the command line.
And sure enough, it's deploying
in this web interface.
So these are
different clients all
talking to the same
REST interface.
And it also means that
third party vendors
are able to integrate with
these same open source REST APIs
using auto generated libraries.
So we have native
support in things
like Apache Airflow, in
Luigi, in Python mrjob.
So in all these open
source projects,
you can get Dataproc
support out of the box.
Also show what it looks like
to create a cluster entirely
from the UI.
You just select the dropdown,
give it a name, and hit Enter.
It's that easy.
So there, I created
another cluster.
In fact, let's create
another one, for fun.
In this case, I
mentioned you might
want to use the latest and
greatest versions of Hadoop.
And what might that entail?
Well we always provide
a preview image version,
which has the latest and
greatest software that's
going to be targeted
for the next release.
So right now Hadoop 2.8 hasn't
actually been released yet.
But we build again
snapshots of Hadoop 2.8.
So we can select
this preview image.
And in those four clicks--
I think that was four clicks--
we will have a
Hadoop 2.8 snapshot.
Not official Hadoop 2.8,
but a snapshot cluster
that lets us be ready
for that next release.
So going back to
here, our time command
says that took one
minute and eight seconds,
so actually less
than 90 seconds.
In 68 seconds we've
now deployed a cluster,
and it's ready to go.
The second that it says that
it's done, it is indeed ready.
And I'm going to go ahead
and run an SSH tunnel.
So it sounds tricky, but it's
really just another one liner.
I'm going to do dynamic port
forwarding on port 12345.
-N, so it's not
taking standard input.
And I'm going to start
up a new browser,
point it at that cluster.
And let's see, I have
to turn this off.
So sure enough, this
cluster's ready.
This is your standard
familiar Yarn UI.
So we're not locking you out
of any of your familiar Hadoop
idioms by adding Dataproc.
So we have our five nodes.
This cluster is ready to go.
I mentioned being able to
submit from raw client, so let's
go ahead and SSH
into that, demo-1.
So on this cluster,
I have access
to all my low level clients.
Let's go ahead and run hadoop
jar lib/hadoop-mapreduce.
It's examples.jar.
And we can teragen some data.
And like I mentioned
before also,
drop in replacement for HDFS.
Instead of specifying HDFS path,
I just say gs:// and everything
just works magically.
teragen, let's call it tmp1.
So this is not using
Dataproc's Job API.
So this is just using
the raw Hadoop client.
And here's your
familiar driver output.
It will tell you the status of
your MapReduce job as it goes
and everything.
And sure enough,
as this is running,
we'll see it pop up in Yarn.
So we can see the
status of this.
And in this case, there's
no application tags.
This was one raw, not
through Dataproc's Jobs API.
But at least we can see,
it just works against GCS
without any extra
fancy configuration.
Alternatively, you can use
Dataproc's gcloud command.
So jobs submit.
Specify your cluster.
Specify your JAR file.
And I just have the Hadoop
MapReduce example's JAR local
here.
I'll just open it
and [INAUDIBLE].
So [INAUDIBLE] that JAR.
Standard Hadoop JAR file,
it's all compatible.
I don't have to
recompile it to run
on Dataproc or anything that.
Pull it out of
any Hadoop distro.
And I have this local.
In this terminal, I'm not
SSHed into the cluster.
And if I want, I can completely
seal off this cluster
from the outside world too.
We recently just
launched the ability
to deploy private
IP only clusters.
So you can create clusters
that don't have any public IP
addresses, and you can still
interact with it through all
your Dataproc Jobs API.
And it's just full access
to all GCP services.
So let's go ahead and run this.
And I'm intentionally running
this without any arguments
here just so you can see.
There's no SSH session
here, but we funnel out
the driver outputs.
So I made a mistake.
I didn't give any arguments.
And so the job will fail and
print out this help text.
It will tell me, oh, I need
to specify an argument.
So even though I'm not SSHed
in, but Dataproc's client, job
submission client
preserves the look and feel
of interacting
with these drivers
so that you can up arrow and
you can have a fast development
loop to react to any errors
that are coming from your job.
So let's go ahead and
also specify teragen
demo/teragen_temp2.
In this case, we are submitting
through the Dataproc Jobs API.
So let's see.
I want to show
these side by side,
but my screen's
a little smaller.
In any case, this
look and feel again
preserves what it
feels like to run
from your standard
Hadoop client.
So if you have something that
likes to stash away the driver
output as you're running,
it's easy to switch over
to the Dataproc jobs
client without changing
the way you think about it.
And I just did Control-C there.
Normally I'd be out of luck if
I did Control-C after running
a Hadoop JAR.
But with Dataproc jobs, you
can rejoin waiting for any job.
So I Control-C it.
But I just have to
say wait for that job,
and it just rejoins that driver
stream right where I left off.
I could have thrown
away this laptop,
opened up a brand new
laptop, and continued
without skipping a beat.
And this also means
that that job--
so here was that job that
we intentionally failed.
It gave us help text.
And here is that job that
succeeded, that we just ran.
So ubiquitous access from
different job clients.
You can see the job output here.
So that makes it very easy.
You can check in on your jobs
with your phone if you want.
It's very convenient.
Now, let's see, so going over
this Stackdriver monitoring.
We also enabled
Stackdriver monitoring.
And one concept
I talked about is
using this to provide
overarching monitoring
of multiple different Dataproc
clusters in one place.
So let's create a group here.
We tagged our cluster with--
I believe it was dhuo-live-demo.
So let's call it
dhuo-live-demo here.
And you can filter it by tag.
So let's just say that
if the tag exists,
this constitutes a group.
So this way I can manage
multiple Dataproc clusters
with the same tag and put them
in the same monitoring group.
So let's see what it takes to
create a brand new monitoring
dashboard from scratch and
see if we can do it live.
So I just created a group.
Now all I have to do is go in,
create a brand new dashboard.
It's untitled.
I'll call it dhuo demo, and
start dragging and dropping
to add these charts.
We'll see, there are built in
host side monitoring values.
And so let's see,
network traffic,
let's make it aggregate.
So we use the stack area.
And we can filter by group.
So let's choose our
dhuo-live-demo group.
Great, so now we have a chart.
Data's going to start coming in.
Let's add another chart.
We'll add a couple of these.
Let's see, outbound
is good, filter.
So it's that easy.
All I have to do,
point and click,
and I have myself a nice
monitoring dashboard.
Aside from using
Stackdriver in itself,
you can also just click
through to your cluster-- oh,
that was the wrong cluster--
click through to your
cluster, and there's already
some amount of built-in stuff.
So this was our
teragen job running.
So you can see CPU utilization,
network bytes, and it pops up.
So that we have something
more interesting to monitor,
let's kick off something
a little bit more beefy.
So a bit of a throwback here.
For old times sake, let's
sort of bunch of data.
So I think I have
some data here.
And let's put the
output in terasort.
So let me submit
this job, and we're
going to sort a
bunch of data and see
what monitoring looks like.
We can also take a peek at logs.
So we're well integrated
with Stackdriver Logging.
And what you can
do here is, going
through cloud Dataproc cluster,
you can search for dhou-demo-1.
And sure enough, we
have one cluster there.
And as that job kicks off, we
have these different categories
of logs.
We have daemon logs, so you
can see about the health
of your overall cluster.
There's also user logs.
So user logs will be associated
with each of the jobs.
And this is all funneled
into Stackdriver
so that you can search here.
You can actually create
log-based metrics too.
So that's something that
we recently released
as well with a bit of a
refactor of our logging.
So you can set up
monitoring charts and alerts
based on what kind of
logs are coming through.
So here we have the job
that we just started,
that we just kicked off.
So you can see how
it's kicking off
a lot of individual map tasks,
all your usual stuff usually.
You don't have to
dig through these
unless something goes wrong.
Now taking a look, this is
kind of taking a long time.
I'm impatient.
It took like a minute to get
a third of the way through.
So what does that mean?
Is that 30 minutes
to complete this job?
And yeah, we don't
have that kind of time.
So, we're impatient.
We want to make it run fast.
What can we do?
What if we make this thing have
20 times as much resources.
How hard is it to scale that up?
Well, that was
about four clicks.
I lost count.
But about four clicks later,
we resized our cluster up
to a hundred nodes instead
of just five nodes.
It's not quite done yet.
It's not 100% instantaneous.
But the second we
clicked that, we saw
these GCE VMs start to pop up.
So you see these
green checked boxes.
They're starting to come in.
They still have a little
bit of initialization to do.
But as they come in,
we're going to see
that we have this running job.
And in Yarn we're going to
see this active node count
start going up.
So even in the middle of a
job, we felt that it was slow.
So we can immediately do a
couple of clicks in the console
and immediately start
seeing new nodes come in.
Well we'll take
another look there.
We're also going to--
let's go ahead and add a
few other monitoring charts.
So I use some host
side monitoring.
What we did, I clustered
deployment time,
was we install the Stackdriver
agent, which reports guest,
reported utilization metrics.
So this means we can
even look at fork rate--
sure, why not?
We can look at CPU,
according to the guest,
so that you can see if there's
any kind of discrepancy.
And this one, I guess
we'll split it out
by line instead of stacked.
So that way we can see
sort of the variability
across different nodes.
And another thing is that since
we created this dashboard based
on this tag that's going
to apply to all the VMs,
as we add more VMs,
it will automatically
become part of this chart.
As we have more
clusters, it will also
become part of this
chart, if we're
targeting those other clusters
with the same group tag.
So let's see, what else is fun--
memory used.
Memory used is likely
something that you'd
want to set maybe an alert on
or something like this to see--
or when debugging a job, this
is where you can potentially
look at some skew.
So just by hovering over it,
you can see what kind of skew
you're dealing with.
So some workers might be using
a lot of memory and OOMing.
And you'll find that you need to
chop up your data differently.
So this is also a development
tool for your pipelines.
I should have come
back here earlier.
We missed them coming in.
But sure enough, we have
a hundred active nodes.
So it was that quick.
And actually it comes
in faster than it
takes to deploy a cluster.
We resize it up.
In less than a minute, we
should have our extra capacity.
And also sure enough,
this whole thing sped up.
Should have seen it in
action, but the second we
added all those nodes,
this thing sped up.
And suddenly instead
of waiting 30 minutes,
it's done within the span
of basically our demo.
So let's see, once you're done--
so right, I also created
a Hadoop 2 cluster.
So just for fun, let's
take a peek at that.
I think I called that
3, Hadoop 3, or demo-3.
So here is the shiny new
Hadoop 2.8 UI, subtly
different from Hadoop 2.7.
But if you click
on About, you can
see this is indeed built
from a Hadoop 2.8 snapshot.
So this cluster will be running
Hadoop 2.8 with Spark 2.1.
And in general, this is
a great way to canary.
If you're doing development,
a fast development cycle,
clusters are so
throw away anyway.
If something goes
wrong, throw it away
and you only last a
couple of minutes.
So generally, you can
use this preview image
to stay abreast of all the
developments in the open source
ecosystem and have very agile
development against the latest
and greatest.
So we can wait for
that to finish.
Once you're done
with your clusters,
it's just as easy to
delete your clusters
as it was to create them.
You can click some
checkboxes, click Delete,
delete multiple clusters
at once if you want.
And we're just sorting data.
We don't have to
watch it finish.
So, yeah, it's that easy.
So that about summarizes it.
Let's go back to the slides
and we can recap what we saw.
So again, to recap
where we saw, Dataproc
is built on these
web-based REST APIs that
allow consistent and
ubiquitous access
from a variety of clients,
both from Google-provided tools
like that gcloud command
line and Cloud Console,
as well as third
parties for integration.
So there's a thriving ecosystem
here of things like Airflow
adding orchestration first
class for Dataproc and Luigi
and Python mrjob
that all integrate
with these web-based APIs.
We also saw how job submission
preserves the look and feel,
whether you're using low level
clients or gcloud dataproc job
submit.
But by submitting
through the Jobs API,
you get this value
add of logging,
of job tracking,
of status tracking,
of viewing your job driver
output from the Cloud Console,
and more to come as well.
We also saw that it's trivially
easy to update your cluster,
even in the middle of a job.
So if you underestimated
how much resources your job
would take and you want to
get it done fast, no big deal.
No harm done.
Click a couple of buttons
and you're good to go again.
You can speed up that job.
And finally we saw
integration with Stackdriver,
both on the logging side where
you can see your user logs,
you can see your daemon logs,
and on the monitoring side
where it's easy to
just point and click
in order to create
customized monitoring
dashboards in the same place
across different GCP services,
so that you can monitor
everything, track everything,
set up alerts all
through Stackdriver.
So let's recap
what it looks like
to put together everything
we learned together,
just to illustrate
what this might
look like at various
stages of your migration.
So to begin with, you might have
some amount of archival data.
You might be looking to
free up space on-premise.
So you're trying to
archive some data to GCS.
Maybe you're trying to set up
disaster recovery, so backing
up your data to GCS already.
In such a case it
becomes very natural,
even if you're not forcing
any kind of compute migration,
to start adopting
Dataproc ad-hoc.
So oftentimes what
happens is some kind
of unexpected backfill
that you otherwise
wouldn't be able to accommodate
on-premise, no big deal.
You can run it and
you can run it quickly
on Dataproc bursting into cloud.
New development-- why
constrain yourself
to working on your
development cycle
according to whatever scraps
are available on-premise when
instead you can sort
of burst into cloud
and feel free to break things
as much as you want and not
worry about production
as you're doing it?
In the interim, you might
find yourself with somewhat
of a hybrid cloud setup.
So by using a VPN tunnel to
bridge your on-premise network
with a GCE network,
Dataproc natively
supports deploying onto
these same subnetworks
so that they can talk natively
to your on-premise clusters.
And they might be
pulling some of the data.
They might be helping mediate
some of your data transfer.
They might also be doing
ETL or analytics directly
against your on-premise cluster.
So either way they're augmenting
your on-premise cluster.
And in the meantime
on the other side,
you'll find that you still
have some subset of things
as more of your data starts
making use of GCP's storage
options.
You'll find that you can
burst your development
pipeline still.
So same idea as purely
bursting into the cloud,
but these will be augmenting
your overall platform, even
with Dataproc clusters that
aren't directly accessing
your on-premise cluster.
And finally we see a
cloud native architecture
where everything is
based on cloud storage.
And again, instead
of any Hadoop cluster
being your universe of
data analytics tooling,
GCP as a whole is
your data platform.
And you'll be able to unify all
of your logging and monitoring
across different tools in
one place using Stackdriver.
You might find third
party tools to be
useful for performing your
scheduling and orchestration
and productionisation
of your Dataproc jobs.
And you'll likely find some
mixture of completely ephemeral
jobs that are very hands
off, easy to manage,
while others that might not
have come along so easily
but still are amenable to
semi-long lived clusters.
And again, with
semi-long lived clusters,
you still eliminate
the headaches
of worrying about this
two-year-old cluster where
you're worried that a gust
of wind might blow it over
and you don't want to touch it.
Here, you can canary brand
new versions of software.
And if a new guy comes in and
breaks an entire production
cluster, no big deal.
You throw it away, create a
new one, let it join the group.
And it's that easy to
manage your infrastructure.
So that pretty much
concludes today's session.
A couple of related sessions
include this afternoon,
there's going to be BD205, which
is a more higher level view
of Dataproc with some neat
demos, less migration oriented.
Machine learning
on Spark MLlib is
going to be tomorrow morning.
And IO321 was concurrent
with this one,
but you can catch it
on recorded sessions
if you have the time for a
deeper infrastructure level
dive into GCS performance.
Just some doc links--
you can find a lot of good
reading materials under
cloud.google.com/dataproc.
You can also see those
initialization actions
I talked about hosted
on GitHub and maintained
by the Google team, along with a
lot of ecosystem contributions.
And various sources of help--
naturally you'll have your
Cloud Support contracts
where you can contact high level
escalations of Cloud Support
troubleshooting.
There's also a very active
StackOverflow community.
And of course under our normal
cloud.google.com documentation,
you can find a lot
of helpful links.
So thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]